- NO, NO! WAIT TILL AFTER THE PATS GAME.
- This season’s been pretty dark.
Thank God for the Quarter-Season Carnival!
- MY WHOLE FAMILY PLAYS FOOTBALL.
- Yeah, I know, man. Relax.
- STEP RIGHT UP TO THE WORLD OF SUCK!
AHHH! WHAT IS THAT THING?!
- Sometimes I’m 5’10”.
-Aw, fluff.
- Drop me anyway.
OH NOOOO.
- Hey, Cincinnati, I hit the board!
- INTERCEPTED! And it’s coming back!
- AH!
- You did it, Kirk.
- LIFE IS A CARNIVAL, YOU SEE?
YOU GOT ONE DOLLAR AND-
- Come on… come on...
- Sorry. It’s not safe for you to scramble.
- I understand...
-This ride’s not for everyone.
- I can handle it, Russ.
- I’M SURPRISINGLY KEEPING UP.
- I can scramble foreeeeeever.
- DON’T SLOW THE TEMPO. LET ME FLY.
- Hey, man, you do whatever you want at this point.
I don’t care.
- THIS IS NORMALLY WHEN I STOP.
- Watch this, haters. Swish.
- No, I prove the haters wrong.
- Who...are…you?
- I’m Lamar Jackson, and I’m not afraid to die.
- CHECK DOWN! CHECK DOWN!
Wait, where’d he come from?
- IS THIS THE MERRY-GO-ROUND?!?!
-I’m Football’s Tom Brady.
Please buy my special pliability roombas.
-Uh Tom, this is that subscribe thing for Bleacher Report.
-Why would *I* do that?
Can’t you get—
-Hi, I’m Julian Edelman, and I know Tom Brady.
Please subscribe to this channel.